he's not being paid for his work but
ahmed saliu comes here every day
and he's putting his heart and soul into
the work
for ahmed salihu and the other refugees
this is more than just a training
opportunity
i want to do something
to prove who i am and how can i
contribute to the society
a trained electrician he left nigeria to
escape the terror of boko haram he built
a new life for himself in libya then the
civil war broke out and he was forced to
flee again
he only barely survived the journey to
italy by boat
now he's supposed to return there it's
what everybody know that there is no
job in italy even for the citizen
then what about me stranger there in
italy
that's why he's pinned all his hopes on
this class
it's all part of berlin's arrivo pilot
project
ahmed saliyu and 24 other refugees are
being trained for work here in germany
if they can get a trainee contract their
chances of being able to remain in
germany improve
so if you need to talent people then
there is talent people here in your home
in front of your door
then you didn't took them
you still have a mind to send them out
of your
house or out of your
door
then where do you think you can get
italian people
and that includes skilled workers like
ilya kalakou
a painter by profession he lived in
germany for seven years as a boy his
family had fled the war in kosovo
after peace was restored they had to
return
iliya kalaku was nine years old at the
time
the first two years in kosovo i spoke
only german including at school
i could only speak a bit of albania
at home with my father mother and
brothers i spoke only german
this training site is run by berlin's
construction industry the construction
sector desperately needs an influx of
skilled workers
the refugees are now getting a chance to
see where their talents lie
every two days they're introduced to a
different field of work and find out
more about prospective employers
today ilya kalaku is working with the
plasterers it's a career that suits him
and now he's getting a chance to show
that he has what it takes
this is fun it's really fun
today ahmed salihu is working with the
duct builders
thus far he's received only top marks
from the instructors here even though he
doesn't speak much german yet he has no
trouble following the teacher's
instructions
he's also a quick study here with the
bricklaying his instructor is pleased
with his
but the young nigerian can't get a work
permit in germany instead the
authorities want to return him to italy
but every morning he's back at the
training center
actually i can learn what i didn't know
before it's nice
the project social worker wants to help
she's planning to submit an appeal for
ahmed salihu so that he can stay
this
he's not only someone who's politically
active here who's learning german and
who's built up a solid network in berlin
he's also the kind of person that
employers are looking to hire
many german companies are also starting
to ask why they can't benefit from
workers like ahmed salihu
that's why the project is floating a
trial balloon they've selected three
refugees who will first get an
internship and then be referred to a
trainee spot
ilia kalaku is one of them today he's
poured his first plaster column and he's
come one step closer to his dream of
being able to live and work in germany